todo el mundo ha seguido con atención
adquisición de Twitter por parte de Long
Mask incluida la Unión Europea la
comisión Europea de hecho allá ha
enviado un mensaje de que las normas
europeas se deberán seguir cumpliendo en
particular el comisario europeo de
Mercado interior terribletón a través de
la red social Twitter ha dejado muy
claro que el pájaro seguirá volando Pero
siempre y cuando se adhiera a las normas
regulatorias europeas en particular se
refiere a una serie de leyes aprobadas
en los últimos meses por parte de la
Unión Europea una de ellas es la ley de
servicios digitales que obliga a las
compañías tecnológicas a retirar
rápidamente el contenido ilegal y
también a tener más transparencia y
Claridad en los algoritmos que utilizan
estas empresas además también se deberá
retirar en esta ley contenido por
ejemplo imágenes y vídeos de personas
que sean de contenido personal y por lo
tanto se deberá retirar también así como
discursos del odio también en campañas
electorales por ejemplo para evitar
casos como el de Cambridge analítica aún
así se va a seguir velando por la
libertad de expresión y también los
derechos fundamentales en cualquier caso
tierra libretón que se reunió con elon
musk el pasado mayo el multimillonario
le aseguró estar muy a favor de esta ley
y que está en cumplimiento con los
objetivos de la empresa